je suis aurait pu rater le directeur
général du groupe angélistes qui
s'occupe de restauration d'immeubles et
aujourd'hui je vous présente et le
château de crespières dans le 78 entre
orgeval et plaisir allez on y va
suivez-moi
[Musique]
ans
il a été fini de construire fin du
xviiie siècle et ensuite il est passé de
famille en famille et le dernier
occupant qui a quitté les lieux en 1989
c'était donc michel bourbon de parme qui
est donc le petit fils du duc de parme
montpon gélis s'est porté acquéreur et
va maintenant rénover ce château lui
redonnant toutes ses lettres de noblesse
avec notamment 12 logements qui vont du
t3 au t4 duplex évidemment des places de
parking les travaux de rénovation sont
vraiment très très lourd puisque la
toiture est effondré les escaliers
intérieurs sont effondrés les planches
et aussi donc ça va nécessiter au
minimum 30 mois de travaux le château
est constitué de deux tours avec un look
pièce centrale et vous avez un retour
sur la tour de droite dans laquelle il y
aura également des logements qui vont
donc être achetés soit par des gens qui
veulent y habiter soit des gens qui
veulent faire de l'investissement dans
le cadre du dispositif final c'est tout
à fait possible donc je pense qu'on aura
aucune difficulté à vendre du locle à de
magnifiques et la proximité notamment de
paris
donc là on arrive sur la partie arrière
du château où cette partie arrière sera
composée de petits jardins avec des
chemins carrossables pour les pour les
habitants
[Musique]
bon
si c'est une des rares pièces
dans laquelle on peut rentrer sans se
prendre une pierre sur la figure donc on
voit les aspects arrondi
on voit qu'il y avait des tentures
d'un tas de choses intéressantes en
terme de décoration qui est évidemment
très dégradé on va pouvoir sortir cette
opération aux alentours de 5900 euros du
m
et si on rajoute les parkings on sera
aux alentours de 6000 6100 euros
puisqu'il y aura deux parkings par par
logement